foreign
[Music]
moved in here it wasn't as warm as we
hoped
okay I'm gonna light a vanilla candle
and it's going to be a game changer
and after midnight the house comes alive
this place is haunted
we need your help
it's time to assemble the Dream Team we
find someone who can communicate with
these ghosts
people used to eat here I told you she's
good oh it's a dining room
I found a professor who else wanted
mansions I've been dying to go to this
place for years Mr
lurks around every corner
I can show you what happened but it will
cost you
three dollars
who said that
you're not that scary you're really not
terrifying can you turn it around just
while I finish this thank you
guys is anybody else
if we don't solve this mystery
we're stuck here for eternity
you're all in for a treat
laughs
[Music]